THAN 1,000.
NOW BACK TO JESSE.
JESSE: PRESIDENT HAS A TOUGH
DECISION TO MAKE SOON.
WHEN TO OPEN THE ECONOMY BACK UP
AND HOW, AND MSNBS SAID TRADING
DEBT FOR DOLLAR.
NOW MAKING ARGUMENT LET THE
WORLD
WORLD WAR II VETS DIE AND
VIETNAM VETS DIE LET EVEN IN
THAT GENERATION DIE.
WE’RE WORRIED ABOUT BOEING IT IS
BORN, IT IS THE WEAKEST AMONG
US, IT IS SENIOR AS THES.
READY TO EUTHANIZE --
BECAUSE THEY WANT BOEING’S
CORPORATE EARNINGS TO NOT DIP
TOO LOW.
JESSE: JOINING ME NOW HOST OF
THE WAR ROOM PANDEMIC RADIO
SHOW, STEVE BANNON, SO STEVE
WHAT’S THE CALCULATION FOR
OPENING THIS BACK UP?
STEVE: I THINK THE PRESIDENT YOU
LOOK AT WHAT CHAIRMAN POWELL
SAID WHEN HE WENT ON TV YOU HAVE
TO PUT THIS VIRUS IN BACK OF US
AND THEN OPEN IT UP THAT 2.2
TRILLION TRILLION PACKAGE THAT
TOOK ON ECONOMIC CRISIS THAT
DROP IN AGGREGATE DEMAND HAS
DONE IS A START.
BUT YOU HAVE TO BRIDGE THE WHOLE
THING.
I’M ACTUALLY AN ADVOCATE JESSE
AND I THINK THAT DATA WILL GET
PRESIDENT TRUMP THERE AND PEOPLE
SHOULD UNDERSTAND.
HE’S A BUSINESS GUY HE’S VERY
NUMBERS AND DATA DRIVEN.
I THINK YOU’RE GOING TO SEE A
BIG SHIRT OVER THIS WEEKEND
WHERE HE’S GOING TO SIT THERE
AND GO HEY RIGHT NOW WE’RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO KEEP IT AND MAYBE
EVEN INCREASE LOCKDOWN WHICH I’M
A BIG ADVOCATE OF.
I THINK IN YOUR OPENING SEGMENT
TO ME, WAS ONE OF THE MOST
POWERFUL THINGS THAT I’VE SEEN
IN MEDIA GOT TO BE PLAYED
EVERYWHERE IF YOU SEE THAT I
THINK YOU GO TO EVEN AD HARDER
LOCKDOWN RIGHT NOW.
A HARDER E LOCKDOWN RIGHT NOW
AND THEN WE BRING NOBODY SHOULD
LOSE A JOB, NO COMPANY SHOULD GO
OUT OF BUSINESS, WE’VE GOT TO
BRIDGE THE SMALL COMPANIES THE
ENTREPRENEURS TO GET TO OTHER
SIDE IF YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH
HELL, ABOUT GO THROUGH THIS FAST
AS POSSIBLE.
THE PRESIDENT IS A WARTIME
PRESIDENT.
HE’S MADE SOME TOUGH CALL AS
ALREADY.
HE’S SHUT DOWN ALL OF THE
TRAFFIC COMING IN FROM CHINA ANY
QUARANTINE EVERYBODY THAT CAME
BACK AND HE WAS CRITICIZED BY
MORNING JOE AND BIDEN AND THOSE
GUYS AS BEING RACIST AND ZEN
PHOBIC MADE RIGHT DECISIONS I
HAPPEN TO THINK NUMBERS SHOW HIM
WHERE NEW YORK IS GOING AND
WHERE NEW ORLEANS IS GOING AND
WHERE DETROIT IS GOING THAT WE
KEEP THIS IN A HARDER LOCKDOWN
AT LEAST THROUGH EASTER AND THEN
SEE WHERE WE ARE.
AND YOUR COLLEAGUE STEVE HILTON
I THINK HAD A GOOD PROGRAM LAST
WEEK BUT I WOULD DISAGREE IN
FACT THAT IT IS NOT A EITHER OR.
YOU’VE GOT TO BRIDGE YOU’VE
GOT --
AND POWELL SAID THIS THIS WEEK
ABOUT YOU HAVE TO BRIDGE ECONOMY
TO GET OVER IT CHASM.
I THINK THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
GOING TO COME TO CONCLUSION HEY
I WANT TO EVEN TIGHTEN THIS
THING UP SOME MORE TO GET
THROUGH THIS QUICKER FASTER TO
HAVE A STEEPER REVIVAL AND I
THINK THAT’S WHAT, I BELIEVE
THAT’S WHAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN I
THINK THAT IS RIGHT THING TO